And Kelly just leaked it. >> It's not primary. She tweeted
it. She always tweeted it. You're lying. She tweeted that >> bully
to you here. Okay. Kelly, what's
>> Uh, what do you think? What's up? >> Multiple
times. >> I'm sorry. Both you and Cherry said that the
message that I sent her when she was in the mental hospital was
the nicest she'd ever had. Am I like not correct about this?
What about all of the other times in the last 6 months where
she'll say something mean and then block? What was that? He constantly
blocks friends. >> I just want to point out that that is
actually something that is private. That would be >> You're
so empathetic that you're streaming this. And are we calling
the traumatic event where you had her
>> All right.
Okay.
>> Okay. Uh I was told I should drag Kelly in. Let's go.
>> What is she saying? She's apparently going off. Hold
on. Let me pull into here. Okay. Kelly, what's up?
>> Uh, what do you think? What's up? >> What's up?
How's it going?
>> What do you think is what's up?
>> Uh, I think you're mad that you don't have perms in
the Discord anymore. >> You think that's why I'm mad? >> Or
are you mad for me calling you out publicly about adding straight
raid?
I no I think I'm mad because we had a private discussion earlier
about and then I think you're making it about straight raid when
it's not and I think you should have DM'd me and said hey >> it's
definitely not totally about straight raid at all.
>> All right. Well, I'm glad I was correct about that.
I think you should have DM'd me about this instead of like publicly
chastising me. Yeah, obviously because >> I was super I
was super annoyed about the straight raid thing though. >> it
was a single ping where all I said was everything is okay.
>> Like, you think she was like distraught by that or like
that bothered? You think that a streamer doesn't turn pings off
when they stream? >> I don't >> in a gen chat. >> I
don't care. >> Well, it matters. >> You pinged her
multiple times over the past couple days. >> I pinged her.
Yeah. The other day. Yes. >> You didn't say anything then.
>> I didn't know you did it.
>> Okay. You're just randomly pinging notables to talk
about them. Why?
>> Uh because nobody else will because you're sweeping
so hard. >> So we're not allowed to like talk people now
and not allowed to stir or is it just that like when you >> You
can totally You can say whatever you want in Gen Chat, I guess.
But I just don't know why you're pinging straight raid while
you're like trying to annoy >> Well, apparently I can't
say what I want because you wouldn't have taken the perms away
for me to be able to do that.
>> Okay. Uh I So you can say whatever you want. You just
have to deal with the consequences of saying what you want.
>> Yeah. The consequences are you taking the ability for
me of me away from me to do that thing.
>> So I can't do that thing because those are the consequences
of it. So why are you saying I can do something I can't?
>> Uh sorry. You had the ability to and now you can.
>> Yes. No. But what kind of pointless statement is that
to make
>> that like you can I'm not going to tell you what you
can and can't say, but if you're obviously abusing whatever permissions
you have, then I'm going to take them.
>> I'm not going to say what you can and can't do, but
I am going to restrict your ability to do what you want. >> Yeah.
Like if you just spam the hard R a whole bunch and couldn't be
banned because you had like admin or something, I would probably
take admin away from >> Yeah. Is this really comparable?
Is it me pinging a single time and saying everything is okay?
>> Which you've already admitted. >> Uh yeah, the
other day, which you didn't even know about before you took this
away, did you? Because you didn't mention it or speak to me about
it. I'm sure you just went and looked it up just so you could
on me even though you didn't give a like 3 days ago. >> No,
somebody mentioned it when I pointed out that you did it yesterday
or this >> Oh, who was the someone? I'm very
>> I don't I literally don't remember.
You don't remember.
>> So, I put in the gen chat, "Why are you doing this?
Don't ping somebody while they're streaming." As you didn't engage
with that at all, right? And because you didn't engage with that,
I took away your ability to ping those people. >> Yeah,
because you didn't give a [__] when I multiple pinged
other people in the past. Like, you didn't give a when I did
it to Dioro, who thought it was
>> Uh, I mean, >> everyone thought that was funny.
>> Sure. So yeah, that's not very consistent, is it?
>> Uh, it's definitely consistent. I think I was having
a fight with Nicholas at that time. >> So we can ping notables
when you don't like them. >> Yes. When if they leave, I
don't care. >> that's such a nonsense rule.
>> Okay. Uh, I don't You'd have to You'd have to like try
to argue why it's a nonsense rule. Hey, I like having people
here who will come on stream who I like and have good relationships
with. You're like, well, and you you let me ping the people you
don't like and don't want relationships with. Yeah, actually.
>> And is you pinging me in g chat saying I don't like
you or want a relationship with you. Is that the point? >> I
mean, it's saying we're fighting right now. It's not No, I didn't
say that. It's saying we're fighting right now,
if you don't know that you're live or they're live. Um, >> does
it matter? What kind of streamer
>> I would say the the stream was linked two seconds before
that.
>> I'm sorry, but that's like the sign of an incompetent
streamer if they don't mute the pings from a general chat that
isn't even the Discord.
>> Like, what am I supposed to do? >> Nonsequator.
Complete nonsequitator for the argument. It does matter because
you're trying to imply that pinging someone in a Discord is significant
in some way.
>> What is the significance?
Like what difference does it make?
>> What does
uh because you might get their attention and like screw them
up during a debate. You just ping somebody for no reason. They're
my Discord and they're a content creator. I'm going to get annoyed
about it obviously.
And I think that if they haven't viewed pings and get distracted
by a single ping in a Discord that isn't even theirs, they deserve
to be distracted because they're a idiot. >> So that opinion
is why you don't have the permission to do that anymore. >> I
think that you are a >> Okay, I don't care about your opinion.
>> So why am I even here? >> Uh on like what I am.
I'm just saying you're mad. So go ahead. Go off. >> If
you don't care about my opinion, why would I bother speaking?
>> You don't have to speak. I thought you wanted to talk.
No, I'm here because other people would call me a coward and
accuse me of running if I didn't.
>> Like what? >> So your whole thing So your whole
thing is I'm going to act like a toddler and smash things and
then when people get mad at me smashing things or when I when
I get like actual consequences, actual punishment for breaking
things, I'm going to act further like a toddler.
>> What are Cher's consequences for all the she did? because
you criticized me for simply saying I'm not okay with her because
of the she's done. She doesn't get consequences, does she? She
can be a toddler and nothing happens. In fact, I get criticized
for simply saying anything about it. >> Uh so what happened
was >> you started trying to fight with Cherry for no reason.
>> I didn't start it >> for literally no reason.
And I messaged you. I messaged you and said, "Hey, Kelly Cherry
just had some like traumatic go down like less than a week ago.
Could you maybe show a little empathy, please, and and chill
and you lost your mind?"
>> Is that what is that what's true? I don't think I lost
my mind at all. And I >> Here's the thing. Here's the thing
that you might not understand also, Kelly. >> Okay. Why
can I just ask why you want to be treated like Cherry?
>> I'm saying that you're a hypocrite. I'm not saying I
want to be treated like >> because I'm asking my friend
to treat the person that I'm in a relationship with with like
some amount of respect or
>> Oh, so you're in a relationship again. Okay. Well, I
don't know this. Why would anyone know this? >> I think
I said yesterday we were >> I wasn't around the whole of
the weekend just to call. You knew I was at the beach. Why the
would I know that you're back together? You don't speak to me
in DMs and tell me anything, do you? >> Said this publicly
knew this. I wasn't here on stream. You know, I wasn't here.
>> I wasn't on the stream. I wasn't watching the stream.
Why the would I know that? >> Okay. You don't tell me.
>> I'm curious. Okay. Then then that's like uh obviously
somebody I care about that I've had like a very close relationship
with in the past like month. Why do you want to be treated the
same as them? >> Do I not be
some level of respect? Like you're No. the the reason you're
treating her different isn't >> was some level of respect
was hey reminding you of the situation being like hey could you
just show a little empathy and your answer was no
>> have I been empathetic and understanding and kind dozens
of times in the past when she's been a
>> what do you mean no >> actually famously so
>> I said no you haven't been empathetic in the past multiple
times >> I'm sorry both You and Cherry said that the message
that I sent her when she was in the mental hospital was the nicest
she'd ever had. Am I like not correct about this? What about
all of the other times in the last 6 months where she'll say
something mean and then block?
>> She constantly blocks her friends. >> I just want
to point out that that is actually something that is private
and Kelly just leaked it. >> It's not private. She tweeted
it. >> She tweeted it. You're lying. She tweeted that.
>> She tweeted it.
What are you What are you accusing me of? That wasn't private.
She tweeted it. She said, "I'm an idiot." You might actually
have a point of that. This message was really nice. I feel like
an >> Yes. Congratulations. You're a freak. Like, she tweeted
a bunch of about me, which you conveniently >> Hold on.
Do you Do you not leak things? >> I just assumed it was
another one of these things. >> I will leak petty because
I don't agree with being treated poorly in private and keeping
it private. If you abuse people in private, you have no right
to have that privacy kept.
>> Which what? Okay. I don't understand what the what the
uh abuse is where you leak things about me constantly. But >> no,
that's like that's an abusive relationship where someone is repeatedly
to you and makes demands but expects like privacy.
You get privacy. Like I will never leak anything that's super
serious about anyone because that's just like there's no need
for that. But if it's relevant to the things I'm talking about
or it's just really petty, then yes.
But I've said that to you multiple times. This is not new information.
If this was an issue, you shouldn't have been friends with me
for the last six [__] months. >> You leak literally
everything in our DMs except like the like you you basically
leak everything. You've to some extent leaked.
I told you. >> Do you mean does I will start saying actual
serious stuff so we can like determine that that's not true.
I will start DMing you. All of the stuff that I know that I know
that is serious that I've never spoken about. >> Okay,
go ahead. >> You You want me to start writing them all
out? Sure. >> You could you could DM me. Sure. >> I
can definitely send you at least one.
>> Okay, go for it.
>> I just want to point out that the thing that started
this fight really
is me saying, "Hey, could you just show a little empathy right
now?
Just saying.
>> Uh I that second part definitely didn't happen. The
first part did.
>> Uh you're not saying that you didn't say any of those
things. I I don't know why you would disagree, but okay. There
was a lot of criticism and negative [__] I don't
know how you think I wouldn't come to that conclusion after the
things you told me.
I have been empathetic and understanding on multiple occasions.
And also everyone else in this community who's also been blocked
multiple times by Cherry understands that this is a thing and
you're like trying to like it feels kind >> upset that
you got blocked by somebody. You need like help. >> No,
that's not it. It's the things that she says before she does
that. Like accusing me of being a cult member and all that other
[__]
It's that like I'll be nice and be like checking in on her and
be like, "Are you okay?" And then she'll just say something.
>> But I accepted that and I took that cuz it was in private.
So I was like, "Okay." She's like having a time each time she
like says something and disappears and blocks people again. But
when she starts tweeting stuffing stuff in public
out of context that's not even true for reasons I don't understand
cuz I hadn't done anything
then you expect me to just eat
because you eat on a daily basis I guess. >> Yeah. When
I like am friends with people I don't take like one petty difference
and immediately blow up those friendships like completely.
>> But you was this one petty difference.
>> This was a one petty thing. >> Yes. And you you
ignored my DMs
>> after I'm trying to talk to you about this stuff in
public private, sorry. And then you are surprised I get mad when
I was already mad when you're criticizing me for being mad for
valid reasons. >> Well, you're mad because I took your
your perms away. I have already mad entirely to do. >> Oh
my god. I'm not mad because of the perms, you clown.
>> What are you mad about?
I'm mad because you were to start with you're trying to get me
to apologize to someone when they've been like to me or like
give extra empathy and be kind and understanding for reasons
I don't know because you do you like eat [__] all
the time but like I don't know why I should. So, you're criticizing
me for the way that someone is poorly treating me and then you
criticize me publicly for like pinging straight aid once in a
harmless
and then you do you don't like respond to my DMs. So, >> wasn't
a harmless context. And it wasn't a harmless context yesterday
either. >> Yes, it was. It definitely was today. >> Couple
days ago.
>> All I did a couple days ago was call her a chicken.
>> Is that really a problem?
Uh, wait. What did you say? Oh, make a statement. You were like
adding her about the same thing you've been looping on for the
past like 6 months. >> It's not what I've been looping
on for 6 months. It's what I brought up recently in her content.
And I think it's >> You've brought it up multiple times
because every time I ever ever talk about Straight Raid or have
a talk with Straight Raid, you have to point out how mad you
are about Straight Raid. >> Matt. Okay. You're like constantly
misrepresenting everything I've ever said. But if you want to
look at it like this, then sure. I just think she should make
some kind of a statement because she hasn't said football and
it's weird and I'm not the only one that thinks and feels that
way.
>> I don't know why Cherry is saying I have not escalated
or ask for anything. She tweeted a bunch of insane and then are
like surprised that I am annoyed. I don't
That's how normal people respond. >> It's really not. I
don't know. I feel like I could try to explain. Who is >> You
don't feel it. You don't understand it. You've never felt it
in your life.
>> it's going to >> I'm sorry. Is empathy when >> empathy
is when you know that somebody's gone through a traumatic situation
which you knew last week and you were very understanding of and
then Char said something negative about you and your empathy
disappeared entirely. You had no empathy remaining. You suddenly
had zero empathy for her. Negative empathy for her. I don't understand
where that how that happens or why that happens, Kelly. I don't
understand why when somebody says something bad about you, you
go, "Oh, I'm really concerned about this person. I'm really concerned
about this person. Them them. Oh my god, them. I don't understand
how this isn't the first time. I don't get why that happens with
you. I do not get why that happens with you. >> This is
not the first time she's done this. I don't know why you're misrepresenting
and lying like this. I have accepted it and understood and forgiven
it on multiple occasions.
Why are you trying to imply that I haven't?" Do you think Cherry's
not done the same thing with you and that about that you've said?
>> The one thing that happened a year ago that I apologize
for. Yes. But she keeps bringing it up like I'm going to >> How
did you apologize exactly?
>> I apologize to her multiple times, including in DMs.
>> Or are you trying to imply that that wasn't an issue?
>> That's how you apologize because I don't think you really
are capable. So, >> I think that this is interesting that
this type of language is coming from you considering all of the
things that you've said about Cherry when you're not on good
terms with her. I think you're being very hypocritical. >> You
are. Oh my god. Let's go, Kelly
>> Yes. Because you're trying to represent things quite
somebody did ask me. Okay. Somebody did ask me why I wasn't going
to debate Kelly Gene on stream. And I said the second she like
loses any point, she'll just leak something private immediately.
>> You do realize I didn't actually leak anything there.
So, not only did I predict exactly when you'd go into the VC,
but I also predicted exactly when you would leak things in this
>> Oh my god. I didn't even leak anything. I just said
that you've spoken about people. Is that like really a surprise?
>> You've even like said that's not >> It's like
all so predictable. It's just like all immediately obvious that
it will happen. So, I wasn't going to talk to you at all today,
but instead I'm actually just sitting here and doing it and going,
"Look, I was right again. Look, I was right again. Look, I was
right again. >> No, because if I wanted to leak, I would
just say what you actually said.
>> I'm pointing out that you're being too fake, hypocritical.
>> I'm just watching. >> I'm just saying that. Okay,
you would always say I don't negotiate with terrorists, but then
you dated one and are dating one, so I just think that you're
full of >> Can I I don't want to point out what's funny
about that. I won't. It's fine. >> That's probably cuz
you're not capable of being funny, but sure. >> Well, I
just think it's funny. Who did I say I didn't deal with terrorists
over? Who's the terrorist I want to deal with? >> To me,
over one single incident, but you'll accept Cherry being insane
over and over and over again and then criticize me for it. And
are we calling the traumatic event where you had her
>> is that? The traumatic event? >> Like I don't
know what you're referencing when you say that.
>> Okay. You never you never expected baby poison ever
in a million years. So, does that mean you traumatized her? Like,
what are you saying when you say that?
>> Is that your fault? >> Uh, I would probably just
go look at the
>> I don't know why you're trying to You're trying to like
twist a knife for >> What statement?
>> I don't have to go into anything personal or private
about you, Kelly. Argument, right? But you have to go into all
kinds of personal private things with me. >> Sorry. What
of that was >> Everybody Everybody can see it. Everybody
can watch it happen. We're just doing this in in public. It's
fine. >> Sorry. What was What if anything I just said was
private? I'm referencing private, no public tweets even.
>> Oh, you can't see Kelly right now. Where is it? Oh,
what the hell? >> Sorry. Please explain anything what I
just said that was wasn't public
>> What? I said personal stuff. Personal.
>> Okay. Personal involves some level of
>> So, you want to have this discussion and
Sorry, what do you mean? >> When I say something's personal,
I mean it's like it's like a personal thing that you wouldn't
really want uh brought up. And you know exactly what those are
like cuz you have those things for yourself. But you'll you'll
bring them up about other people when you can when you want.
>> No, you're accusing there being a trauma that happened
recently. But like that's implying that you traumatized them.
You just said
as in last week. That's why I was asking you if that is the trauma.
>> I didn't say trauma. I said I said somebody went through
something last >> You did use the words trauma. You can
double check the VOD if you want. That's why I'm confused.
>> You did say trauma. There you go. Chat >> Um yeah,
I would say that's probably a thing. Yes. >> Well, then
you're saying you traumatized
>> Okay. Then how is this my fault? >> I thought
you maybe you would have >> Have I had empathy multiple
times in the past? Yes. But it doesn't mean Okay. Nobody's owed
kindness from me. Here's the thing. Especially when they have
been unkind to me. >> No empathy. You have no empathy for
anybody who is not nice to you dayto-day. Zero. >> That's
not true. I've been empathetic to Cherry when she's been to me
on multiple
>> And you've like
you know this cuz I've spoken to you each time it happens. Or
are we just like going amnesia where we don't forget all the
times that she's blocked us after like saying like weird things?
People have like criticized me for being too babying of her indirectly.
Like pop marrows go skitso every time like I'm saying she should
be allowed in this community. She shouldn't be like kept away
like she's a fragile thing made of glass. She should be able
to do what she likes online and she shouldn't be like
ostracized. I don't agree with any of those things. >> I
don't even know what you're talking about right now. I've argued
with Pomero about this on multiple occasions.
>> Okay, why is that relevant?
>> Because I am You just said I have no empathy because
I have no understanding. And that's just not true. And I have
forgiven and let it go on multiple other occasions. But you're
saying I should just do that permanently forever because
question mark.
I don't know why you think I think you should think that. You
don't have to say in this one case, I probably would have like
considered it.
>> You could have easily just blocked and walked away and
just been like, I don't want to be around these people, >> right?
That's not what you did. You wanted to go fight about it.
>> I don't think that anything I said in general chat to
Cherry today was significant at all.
>> I know this being able to understand how someone else
feels. Yes.
But please explain the understanding between all the she said
about me on Twitter that was unprovoked from anything that had
nothing to do it wasn't relevant. It wasn't correct. >> It
had to do with something about that something to do with like
her just getting home and realizing that like um
>> like there was a whole bunch of talk online about her
like haven't actually like confirmed that. You don't think anything
there was going on?
>> Did I say anything negative about her? >> Well,
you have now.
>> I have now. But did I say on that
No is the answer. So I didn't do anything to provoke it. Yes.
>> Well, sorry. Hold on. That's like up to interpretation
though. I don't think you did. But I understand somebody who's
like sensitive and I wouldn't like totally invalidate that. I
could see how they would see some of the things you said and
be like concerned.
>> Yeah. All the times where I said believe Cherry and
like all of that and like don't say anything bad like all like
disagreeing and like shutting down and like the entire stream
was just making fun of you. It wasn't like her at all.
>> Like I don't >> I don't understand the purpose
of >> I don't know what else I could have
>> Probably not within the same week been like Have you
Have you thought about apologizing to me yet? You sent that.
>> I didn't say I didn't say that to her. I wrote that
to you in DMs. >> Wait, how didn't you ask her for an apology?
Maybe not. Maybe it was just in DMs. Hold on. was no. And it
was a point to you in DMs because you were criticizing me, not
because I was demanding an apology for the sake of it. In my
opinion, apologies are just something that people want to give
or they don't. Like demanding one's a waste of time.
>> Who's leaking now? True.
>> People when they don't apologize for tweeting weird
things then act like they have the moral high ground. Lol is
from public gen chat. >> Yeah. Is okay.
>> Is that you asking for an apology,
>> No, I don't think so. I think that's pointing out that
she hasn't given one. >> That's That's not you asking for
Okay. All right. Based
>> that is simply a fact.
>> I don't know why you're laughing. That is a fact. >> I'm
just going to leave this here. Yeah, we all we all think this
is a fact. >> Kelly was not asking for an apology
No, I wasn't. I'm pointing out a fact that that did not happen.
>> Well, it would have looked like I would have looked
like an if she had apologized and I was tweeting. Uh I was writing
that in Discord, right?
>> So, yeah, just making it clear. I don't know why you're
laughing like you've caught me in something.
>> I'm sorry that you're incapable of reading, but that's
what that means. >> No, it's fine. It's fine.
>> You have such a fake laugh.
Oh, it's not fake.
>> It is fake. >> Not over this. No, this is very
funny. >> It's not funny at all. It's a [__]
>> She did tweet [__] and she had an apologize.
All right. I mean, you can laugh at me, but when there's the
inevitable fourth, fifth, sixth mental breakdown that's coming
up, like, good luck with that one cuz I won't be around to help
the next time to build things up
We literally just said that extend a little bit of empathy in
this like just in this this period of time. It's like a week
since this happened. Can we just do a little empathy? >> Pretty
sure you were just laughing at me. You were doing fake laughs
at me.
>> And then you're like, "Oh, Kelly, why aren't you empathetic
whilst I fake laughed at you?" >> No, I Sorry. I'm explaining
what set you off earlier today when I was like, "Hey, could we
show a little empathy? Just like a person's just been through
a traumatic situation. We just >> That's not exactly what
you said to me, is it? That's not what you said. Although you
have deleted your DMs, but I do remember what you said. You were
also critical of me.
>> And that prevents you from doing >> I'm sorry.
Have you spoken to Cherry at all and been like, "Hey, maybe you
should have apologized to Kelly at any
>> Probably not, right? It's only the criticism only gets
headed at >> Hold on. And if I had
>> Well, why didn't you just tell me when I asked you in
DMs?
>> You didn't. >> Oh, because it's like an insane
thing for you to say. Could you Have you thought about Have you
thought about like uh Have you thought about apologizing to Kelly?
>> Why is that an insane thing to say after the stuff she
tweeted? >> Okay. All right. >> Are you going to
answer that or you just going to like imply that that's stupid?
Why is that an insane thing? She couldn't have unblocked me and
sent a hey message or like any message at all.
>> I don't know. Maybe she could have. >> She's done
that every other single time. Why would she have been unincapable
this
>> Uncapable. Um
>> I don't know. >> Yeah. I mean, generally speaking,
people get kind of mad when you just make a fun of the things
that they say, their misspeaks, and then fake laugh at them because
they feel that they're not being respected. So, yes.
Okay, wait. >> You could just ask to be unblocked. Why
should I have to ask for like the dozenth time that you've blocked
and said insane?
Logistical might put up with it again and again and again and
again, but I've already reached my >> Uh, just to be clear,
it wasn't the saying insane that did it.
>> Excuse me. What do you mean? >> It's not like
you freaked out when that happened, right?
you you immediately when that happened you decided you deserved
an apology and then when you didn't get one in a timely enough
fashion for you you started going after the person right >> no
that's not true and also I didn't like instigate some kind of
>> I mean that is objectively true in what
>> no she accused me of harassment and some other and like
was clearly making a passive aggressive comment at me so I >> what
was the passive aggressive comment at you
>> I can read it out
Just want to be clear, me posting straighter aid was to promote
her debate with Hutch, not direct any of you to tag and harass
her to fight about other just removing myself from that. Obviously
a passive aggressive comment at me and then do what you want
if it's within your rules and norms. If I link someone's stream
because I think they're doing a cool debate, I want it to be
clear the you guys did following it was not something I wanted
or thought would happen. So, she posted straight raid stream
and then you added straight raid after you'd been you've been
adding her to like annoy her about her lack of a destiny statement
before. You added straight right after that >> and Cherry
says, "Just so we're clear, I don't want to be a a part of Kelly
like doing this right now." >> And you're like, "Of course,
I'm going to respond to that."
>> Oh, is it as unhinched as all the she tweeted about
me? A single ping where I just said everything is okay. Is that
really comparable to the stuff she said about me? Is it? >> Keep
reading through this. So that happened and then how did you respond?
Let's see here. >> I literally responded pretty light-hearted
to start with. I said, "Girl, I don't care. Go tweet about how
you don't like my clothes some more." And she said like, >> "So
you >> promise when I tweet wanted to tweet something,
I will." >> First tweet back. So you you referenced that
immediately.
>> That was your first. >> Why would I not?
>> No, that was like not the first response. It was like
a few responses down. BS. Dude, >> you know you're going
to look really stupid when the inevitable like fourth and fifth
blowouts happen.
>> Like the fact that you're mocking me from your position
makes you look
>> Wait, do you think um what do you think is is like annoying
here? Frustrating. >> I don't really mind that you find
this annoying and frustrating. I don't like
Hold on. Hold on. Just to be clear,
uh Cherry was just getting back from like a fairly traumatic
thing when she tweeted that stuff. And your response to her going,
"Hey, straighter, I'm not trying to harass you." Was to go like
I guess like Kelly Jean is right. I'll I'll give you that even
was to go uh why don't you go tweet some more insane again. That
was >> I didn't even say that. I said go tweet about how
you don't like absolutely the connotation of your response, right?
>> Oh, so you're saying that what she tweeted was insane.
All right. Glad we
That's what you're implying.
>> No, you don't imply that to me. >> That's what
you think, don't you? Because I didn't say that. >> That's
what you think. It's obvious that's what you think. It's obviously
that's how you're talking. >> Okay. Okay. It's just what
I think. It's not like you said this about like Cherry
>> where she
>> inferred stuff. >> What did I say to you? >> I
don't know what you're What did you say to me when >> about
those tweets? What did I say?
>> I don't know. you delete all your DMs. I don't remember
what you said. >> It was like, "Hey, I think she's just
really sensitive right now. I would just like chill and it'll
be fine in like a while, but just like be chill." >> That
is not true. >> You don't think I tweeted you don't think
I said that to you about these
>> Or not today.
>> Uh, I've said that repeatedly to you.
You've also not understood why things have happened at multiple
times as well because neither of us have understood. If you understand,
maybe that's because you speak to her and have a better understanding.
But I'm in the dark over here and no one's speaking to me about
>> I wish I understood what would make someone want to
do this. Probably when they get repeatedly treated poorly, they
eventually get mad. If I was trying to be cruel, I would say
a lot worse things than I am currently now. This is not the case.
And I would have said cruer things in Gen Chat. There is no intent
to be cruel. Girl, I've at no point convinced him to try and
leave you. Why would I bother? He's a [__]
If he wants to go stick his hand in the fire repeatedly, that's
on him. >> H I just I honestly like I might have a future
as like a fortune teller. I just
it would be shocking to many people here how precisely
I said exactly what would happen here. Just be shocking. >> Did
you ever think at any point of like communicating to me because
I'm fairly sure that you kind of stirred this situation into
happening because you knew I was mad. You did a bunch of other
stuff that you knew would me off and then you're like I predicted
this thing happening that I had. I did know you were I didn't
know you were mad. But then once you're mad, there's like nothing
I could do to to like cool you >> How would you know when
you don't respond to my DMs? If you had asked something from
me, if you had said, >> your your DM was demanding that
I tell Cherry that you should that she should apologize to you."
>> No, I didn't demand that at all. I asked you a question.
Uh, it was you had an expectation that this would have happened,
right? >> It's a question and I'm asking it of you because
it's a criticism of you, not really her. >> Can I read
it? Can I read it? >> Did you even speak to her and suggest
she do something obvious like unblock me and apologize like she
should have a week ago or >> Yes, that's a question.
>> And it's a criticism of the fact that I don't think
that you would have spoken to her about this. You don't expect
her to like do anything about the stuff that she does with anyone
else. She can just do what she wants, I guess.
I want to point out that this is justical's choice to stream
this, >> right? We could have had an offline discussion
about this. Him turning this into content is his choice.
>> We could have, but I was going to stream before people
scream at me for my Discord and said, "Oh, well, I'm not going
to let people say I'm running." >> Is that a valid? Is
that a valid thing to say? I'm not going to let people see say
that I'm running. But it's still your responsibility for turning
this into content >> after I went live. You joined after
I went live. What do I have to do by that same rule?
>> Yep. You don't have to stream this. That is your choice.
>> You didn't have to join the VC. That's your choice.
>> Yep. But you making content of this is your choice.
I'm just pointing that out. >> We're both making the same
choice.
>> Yes. But the difference is I'm not dating this person
who doesn't like the stuff being made into content.
That's not my responsibility. I assume it's yours.
>> So, I just like for all of the Kelly, why aren't you
being empathetic? I think probably streaming this is not an example
of empathy. Justical, but what will I know? >> Especially
since apparently you knew I was going to do X, Y, and Zed. So,
it's not a surprise, was it? You're saying, "Oh, I knew she was
going to do this. I knew she was going to do that." And then
you're like, "Yeah, I'm streaming. I'm going to stream that.
I'm going to make content out of that. I'm going to make money
out of that." You're the person who decided to join a VC the
second I went live, Kelly.
>> Uh, yep. Because you turned off the ability for me to
speak. >> Uh, yeah, as I do for the first hour of every
stream. You have your Discord. >> Yeah, because you took
my perms away. So, you knew that would be the case.
>> Why did I do that? >> I'm saying that you knew
that was going to happen. We're not getting into a circular argument
about whether you feel justified to take my perms away. I'm saying
that you knew the series of events would happen and you're profiting
off of it. >> Okay? So, I don't want you to be like that.
I'm the good guy.
I'm empathy, guys. I'm so empathy.
>> What do you mean what? >> You know, you're stupid
and you don't >> I don't I don't even know what what you
just said makes no sense at all. >> It's making fun of
you. You're saying I'm like so unable to understand empathy,
but you apparently do. >> You are. Uh I am. >> So,
why did you stream this?
because
you wanted to speak publicly about it. >> That doesn't
make sense. So, what Cherry would probably prefer doesn't matter
because I want to have >> You've been speaking publicly
about this in your Discord all over the place. You spam me a
bunch of logs about me, talk about me, all this.
>> What issue do you have with what I've
>> What? Uh, you're just talking about me. >> I have
spoken about it in my 100 person Discord. Yes, big deal
>> I don't know what you think that I've leaked if any
>> people have sent me logs. Three people sent me logs.
You're like talking. >> Then then when I start the stream,
you go enjoy my VC.
>> And then I pulled you in to talk.
>> Yeah. But that's still your choice to make content from
it. Are you dumb? Like you could have not had the stream on.
We could have at any point. >> I can make I make I can
make content out of public comments. Public commentary,
>> Okay. Well, then what would the argument be about? >> Why
is there Why is there any problem with me turning that into stream?
So if you're What do you mean? Of course, you know that Cherry's
complained about this exact thing. She accused us of doing that
stream about people making fun of >> Why? Why are you after
doing all after talking [__] to Cherry after like
getting so mad about her tweets? Are you now trying to invoke
her to say that I'm a bad person for streaming this? >> Because
you're criticizing me for the things that you do. That's the
point. You're not empathetic, but you're coming at me for not
being empathetic. I'm calling you a >> You think I I I
am empathetic. I understand how you feel. I just don't really
appreciate or care that you dictate your feelings entirely off
of how people treat you in any given >> No, because I think
that I don't think you're that empathetic because I don't think
you would have streamed this if you were.
>> Not just because I'm and would have preferred like a
private conversation myself, but because I don't think Cherry
likes this. Whether she's mad at me or you or both is irrelevant.
>> I'm guessing she's mad at you, Kelly. I mean, obviously,
but she's expressed that she doesn't like this thing in the past,
right? She's like literally tweeted about it. So, either she
doesn't really care and only cares in certain
or she does care and just doesn't care. >> what do you
think?
>> I don't know why you're obsessed with wins because I'm
just This is not about winning. I like you have to be >> so
incredibly mentally stunted to think this is about winning or
losing. I'm just annoyed. Okay, >> Kelly, you're expecting
too much from people in this space. Probably I feel like a mug
because I've been around and like spent so many hours, okay,
helping this who just doesn't appreciate it at
>> I will just be your pay pig.
>> Dang devil donated.
>> The appropriate response to every one of these Kelly
blowups should have been to cut her off forever. Inviting this
wretch back into your life as a friend is insanity. And it's
nuts that you have any amount of smuggness about predicting her
behavior.
>> Okay, that last comment might be fair, but the rest
of it is not fair. That last comment is probably fair though
that I shouldn't be smug about the >> Yeah, especially
if you're the ones encouraging them and then willing to stream
them. If you're like really horrified by something I'm doing,
you probably shouldn't stream it, should >> Why not? >> What
do you mean why not? Because if you're saying what I'm doing
is harmful, why would you want to put it on a
>> Because would that just cause more
is probably going to end up on a stream anyway, so why not? >> What
stream? What other person would stream anything that is said
in my discord like that? Like why? >> That is a very interesting
question. I just I kind of wonder if there's anybody who streamed,
you know, inane babble from Kelly's Discord in the past, you
know, month or so. Probably not. I can't. Okay. The comments
that I put in my Discord were not would not have been interesting
to Destiny on their own, but now that it's on your stream, they
would >> Oh, yeah. It's my fault. You're right. You're
right. It's my fault. My bad. >> I mean, go. Okay. Send
me a any message from my Discord that you think he would have
made into stream content on his >> I have no idea.
>> What do you mean you have no idea? Well, send me what
you think is such a
>> I don't I don't have a specific message I think is a
big problem. Kelly, >> do you give Cherry the same hard
time for all the that she tweets and how he made that into content?
Probably not. >> I can't recall. I'm not sure why the >> she
call you.
I don't >> I don't know why the what aboutism. Yeah,
dude. I don't know how many times I have to say it. You are not
the same. You're not equivalent. You're not in the same kind
of relationship at all. I don't know why. >> This isn't
to do with the type of >> Could you imagine? Could you
imagine if it was like a close family member or something that
Kelly was saying this
relationship this other person. >> That's not what I'm
saying. You freak. Like I would ever want to be close to you
in that way at all. I find you like physically repulsive.
>> You've never seen me >> seen enough. >> You've
seen nothing. You've never
seen I offered to uh you a couple people. I said I would get
>> Oh my god. You sent me a picture. I just never clicked
on it to see it in large size cuz I'm not interested. But I did
see it. >> Okay. It was part of like a leaked >> I
don't even know what you're talking >> I just typed it
to you.
>> No, she's talking about something else, I think. >> Yeah,
I'm talking about something else. I'm not talking about the failed
dock
Is it out of line? You're gorgeous. I'm good. If Jessica trusted
Kelly with any sort of sensitive information, I would have to
re-evaluate my opinion of him. You mean his like relationship
doesn't make you evaluate the things that he does?
This guy's clearly a idiot. Do we like forget why last week we
are like like attention span is short? I mean, they can do what
they want. If they're happy, that's fine, but they're both insane.
And I don't think he is is an
>> or a good match in that respect. Like I just want to
point out again that because I don't know, maybe I'm just like
this way, right? Like I
even just being friends like closely for as long as we've been
friends, I would never resort to like trying to go personal in
that way with you ever in reverse. I It's shocking to me that
you are willing to do that. It just like Yeah, it's it's baffling.
>> But I I never I never will go back at you in the same
way. Like I'll never I'll never go back at you in the same way.
got ears and eyes.
>> You're trying to gaslight people that you're not a bit
insane.
>> Uh-huh. Reality re is always okay to confront people.
If you think something's real, it's okay to confront them with
>> Oh, hold on. >> You're going to stream it? Yes.
I'll be >> You can deal with my actual responses. if you
wanted to. >> I just don't understand why you think you
have a leg to stand on with regards to the pickle. Like you you
literally every single like moral uh premise you're putting forward
applies to the pickle perfectly and you should have no issues
with him. >> Um firstly, the fact that you're trying to
invoke something like that is insane and I don't know what that
has in relation to here. Pickle is not my friend. He's someone
that tries to just say cruel things. I've not said something
I've not brought up a cruel thing about Jerry.
>> Okay. I've not brought up a cruel thing about you. I
don't know. Well, there probably could be cruel things I could
bring up about you, but I haven't. >> Okay. Okay.
>> Whilst you're trying to like indirectly hint at something
very cruel, and I don't know why. >> I'm not indirectly
hinting at anything. I'm saying that guy is like, "This is what
I think reality is, and that's why I can go after you with it."
Right. >> He's not doing it because of reality. He's doing
it to be cruel. >> And what's the what's the objective
of calling me or the person I'm seeing crazy? that I am aware
and so is everyone else that you make crazy
>> Like how are these things related at all? I think that
I think that when you're mad at me, this is the type of thing
that you hint to because you know that that's upsetting and you
want to try and be upsetting and cruel. But I haven't hinted
>> I think you've at a traumatic thing at all in this situation.
>> Exact thing. Um >> where when Cherry brought up
the miscarriage thing twice, I did not talk about it.
>> Oh, okay. So when she brings it up
>> but I'm not I'm not even talking about >> engaging
in that. >> She brought it up today. She brought it up
today. Just why are you implying like that's me? >> I'm
not talking about that at all. >> Then what could I possibly
say that is anywhere similar level? There isn't anything else.
There isn't anything as >> You just don't have any empathy
there. You just don't have any empathy for other people. So,
you can't sense that there would be any. >> You're so empathetic
that you're streaming this.
>> If you if you know that I have no empathy, why would
you want to broadcast my lack of empathy? >> Because if
you think that that's harmful,
why would you want to harm someone and talk to >> there?
You know that there's other things you could have done, right?
You could have banned me. That doesn't mean you had to stream.
>> Mhm. And what would have happened if I banned you? >> Well,
I wouldn't have streamed.
No, but she probably would have gone to your Discord and leaked
a bunch of
>> When have I ever leaked in the multiple times that we've
fallen out? When have I ever leaked anything very private?
>> I can't name a single or think of a single time. Kelly,
>> I mean, I could start writing to you again all more
private things that I have kept to myself. I've already given
you some today. >> Do you want me to just like keep going?
>> Yeah, keep going.
Like
I think that you're trying to imply because technically, okay,
last time, a year ago, it wasn't me that leaked it. It was you,
right? But like recently,
what have I done? What have I leaked that's of any significance?
If you want to type it to me because you feel like that is private,
then tell me. >> I'm good. >> I don't think that
you can. >> I think that a lot of things were done publicly
and you're criticizing me for talking about them at all.
Jessica doing the stupid Destiny debate. Okay, true. Actually,
>> there's just I don't know there's much to say.
I mean, you could laugh at me and imply that this is like not
a big deal to you.
>> Whilst also simultaneously like talking about how I
have a lack of empathy and how I am a bad person, but you're
streaming and making revenue and money off of it.
I was streaming already and you decided to come into my Discord
and join the VC in my Discord, Kelly. >> Yeah. And you
decided to drag me in and to then make content off of this. That
was your choice. This is your stream and >> You decided
that you were going to talk about this while I'm streaming. >> Sure.
But it's still your responsibility and your choice. >> Okay.
I'm just saying you responded. You responded, right? And that
you came in here and kept talking. >> Sure. But at any
point you could have cut it off. You could have kicked me out
of this Discord. you didn't make any of those decisions. You
wanted to make content out of it. So, I just I'm not interested
in getting an empathy lecture from someone that makes these decisions,
especially since you've exhibited a lack of empathy towards me
and towards other people on multiple occasions. You've admitted
to multiple people that you've been a friend lately. You've been
distracted and you've been dealing with some stuff, right, for
yourself, right? I don't know why it is that you get to be on
this like moral high ground. >> Okay? Like I'm not coming
at it from the like the position of thinking I'm better than
everyone else because I'm not. I'm just annoyed and I'm mad.
>> You're annoyed about >> I'm annoyed at the way
that you like you speak to me. I think it was pretty disrespectful.
I think that this is a situation that could have been like resolved
if you didn't talk to me like I don't know why Cherry engaged
me in gen chat but she did >> to ask you to hey could you
chill for today? I tried to. I actually was like very nice about
it. Um, I think I was also very clear that like I might not have
said it to you directly, but I said to a bunch of people like,
"Hey, I also have like uh multiple things going on today. Is
it like a busy day for me and I need to be like out of my house
doing these
>> be cool. >> But the conversation that you initially
spoke to me a few hours ago, no, not it was more than a few hours
ago now. The first thing you spoke about me today was the same
conversation that you then decided to publicly bring up in Gen
Chat about straight raid and then like
um chastised me for it. It's not that you removed my perms, it's
that you didn't have that conversation with me in >> When
you have a criticism of me for some reason, Kelly, do you DM
it to me or do you say it directly to me in public? >> I
have DM'd you today. Yes. I asked you a question and you ignored
it. Yes.
>> Okay. When you usually have a criticism for me, Kelly,
is that something you give me in DMs or in public? >> I
always give it to you in DMs first. Always. If you are a and
you ignore me
or you're just like extra hostile for some reason, then I also
do complain if it's petty. >> I don't bring up like super
personal. >> I actually just don't know how we could like
Yeah, we're not operating. Like I man, I don't even know how
to respond to some of it. I think that you're too busy trying
to catch me and some kind of a
lie or something when I've always been very like
I've always been like completely >> When I ask you if you
normally criticize me in public or Yeah, but you but for you
petty like I don't see why the straight raid pinging thing would
be not petty that I couldn't just bring that up in public. just
a totally petty thing
>> because okay, I already said that I bring it up to you
in private first always. If you ignore me and you're then I might
go and like vent about it in public as well, but I always bring
it up to you first in private. Can you give me a single example
where I didn't do that?
>> Uh, no. I can't think of a single time you lied, Kelly.
>> No, that's not why I asked, is it? I said, can you give
me a single example where I didn't come to you in DMs first before
I was It's a reference. Don't worry about it. >> Sorry.
Was that like a Destiny reference? Is that what you're doing
>> Then what was that? >> It's a Lav reference. >> Okay,
whatever. I think that if you're so convinced that that's something
I would do, you would have at least one examp $5. Kelly, he just
lost his virginity last month and now you're trying to destroy
him like this. Leave my man alone. >> Not true. Not true.
That's That's fake
Hold on. Where my Where are my Trump Where are my Trump voices?
>> You are fake news. >> Not cool. Absolutely unequivocally
not
>> Okay, so anyway, either you accepted me for the way
that I am and I think that you did and do
or I don't know why you haven't
like made some kind of ultimatum prior to now
because you haven't. I've said and maintained to you that I will
always leak petty
because I don't think it's cool to like keep that to myself,
especially when you're asking me demented things like to delete
my Discord.
I don't I don't like being expected to keep certain things to
myself, but I always have a discussion with you first. >> Jesus
Christ just tipped $5.
DSTLK is a follower of the biblical text and any claims otherwise
are lies and
>> I don't know if he's there. >> I'm back.
>> Um yeah, but you define what like petty is, right? Like
to me, petty would be you asking me to ban the pickle from Discord
when he's like talking [__] to >> Like you
get really mad when I le something like that, right?
>> I mean, that's
ignoring the context of why I was mad.
Okay. I It feels totally petty. >> You brought it up live
on stream. You brought it up live on stream as I was DMing you
it
>> and you knew that it would make things worse and it
did
>> last time was a complete misunderstanding and I told
you that. >> I thought that you were telling me something
else. >> Times I've said something it doesn't ends up getting
brought up.
you have been like routinely not clear about what you mean and
that's ended up in like significant miscommunications
and I made it really clear to you last time like that's not what
I thought you One of these examples was like me saying, "Hey,
there's this fact about like a certain chatter here that you
you keep drawing attention to. Could you >> And I forget
what I said. I said, "This is bad." Or something. You this person's
upset. And then you did it again. And then you told me that I
didn't tell you not to do it. I just told I told you that it
was upsetting to them.
>> And it's like, why would I why would I tell you that
it's upsetting to them? >> Why would I? >> Yes, that
is that is incredibly poor communication. you should say, "Don't
do this thing." Not just, "It upsets them." Like, why would I
care that someone that I'm not friends with gets annoyed by something
I'm doing when they're annoying me? Almost always that chatter
in question was provoking me and annoying me first. So, you're
telling me this thing upsets them? Okay. Well, I'll use it against
them when they're me off. That's not the same as saying, Kelly,
do not bring this thing up again
or I will kick you, which would have been a straightforward piece
of information.
No, you're laughing, but your communication is terrible. And
I've like I've said to you explicitly, can you please be very
clear with what you want and you never are. And then you get
confused as to why things are like misconstrued.
Like I know
you're like a woman. I don't.
But worse.
>> Okay. Oh, that one is just That was my bad. I shouldn't
have brought That was a funny one. I knew that was how that was
going to go. So, I
got to farm some W's myself sometimes, too. >> The annoying
thing is have I have a how stupid that thing even is.
Especially since like you're saying, "Ah, this thing upsets them."
But the thing that I was saying was it's really dumb. You're
like acting like it's some serious secret thing.
>> Ellie seems actually you have to be direct. True. He
knows this too. And then he laughs about the fact that that's
a requirement I need is for people to be clear, direct, and not
>> I'm sorry. I just don't think I don't know if there's
anyone that >> I don't have this issue with anyone else.
So yes, you are part of the
It takes two to miscommunicate. >> I think you have this
problem with
>> I don't have this problem with everyone. >> Been
around long enough to have these conversations with. >> No,
because my friends are able to be direct and straightforward
and not like nonsensical.
I It's not that difficult.
>> If you have a a demand, you should ask it. Not expect
me to infer it from, hey, this person doesn't like this thing.
It's like that that's a meaningless statement to me. I think
we should I would suggest that is like something that we should
um I would just say as a general rule you probably can't go wrong
if somebody comes to you and says hey this person gets really
like really upset when you do X
just so you know um when when they tell you that they're probably
in 100% of cases saying you shouldn't do X around that person
right
and you're basically arguing that you don't understand that
>> my friends are all capable of being direct with me.
So I don't have this >> That is me being direct. Like there
is no other way to interpret that in normal human language or
relation. >> And I'm telling you that that's not an ask
of me. That is informing me that something bothers someone. That
is not an ask. It's not saying do not say this thing, Kelly,
or I will do X, Y, or Zed. It is simply providing information.
It's not a command. It's not a question. It's not an ask. >> So
you think there's a Okay. You can say in normal people's speech
even though you know I'm even though we've I've explained this
to you what I require when it comes to communication. >> I
think I've
talked to people with actual autism diagnosises and they don't
need that >> and I have one too. I don't know why I say
actual >> sorry sorry sorry. Yeah you I am I not meaning
to cast out on your autism diagnosis. I'm not that was that was
a >> That was a misspeak. >> Well yes. This is like
why do you think that we suffer from miscommunication issues?
It's because things aren't clear.
If you're not and most people aren't direct
for for someone to get to this person has told me this this thing
bothers someone. Therefore,
I should definitely not do it because of insert a consequence.
But if I'm not told what the consequence is, I will not assume
that in any instance at all because it's not a direct thing.
You have to
gain the inference from context, social context clues, which
I don't do. It's been routinely an issue repeatedly over like
the years I've been around, but it doesn't happen with my friends
because they're understanding of this. I don't when I ask them,
hey, can you just be straightforward with me? They just are.
or I ask it from them when I'm speaking to them. Right. >> Okay.
I just don't think I'll just say I just don't think it's a part
of autism that you can't um that you can't connect >> Well,
your ignorance >> most people do understand that like upsetting
people is bad, right? >> Why do you think No, that's not
what that is. Okay. Like when it's
firstly
every single time that that person
I am engaging with, they provoked me first. So, you're saying
I shouldn't say something that that person finds upsetting when
they're trying to upset me? That's stupid. Especially in the
concept of like debate spheres where people are arguing all the
time. You're asking me to be far more empathetic to them than
anyone ever is to me. >> You look bad at me and saying
people with autism usually ask why.
I say like, "Hey, this bothers them." Like why? Or more clarifying
statements. >> Yes, I will ask why. I have asked you why.
And I have like been I don't Are you saying I don't ask you why
for things? We have arguments about why all of the time. >> No,
I mean in that case. >> In that case. I didn't realize
that there was something to argue about. I thought you were just
telling me this person gets annoyed by this. That's what I spoke
on. Empathy. >> Hold on.
>> Empathy and understanding.
>> There's like >> empathy empathy and understanding
is only for BPD. It's not for autism. Sorry. There's no understanding
involved for autism. We just get I thought there was a decent
shot and I was like really bothered by this. So the next time
you're at them, make sure you pull this one out.
>> I mean, that's what I did. >> We both got We both
got our last shot. We both got our last shots in. I don't think
we have to keep going now. I'm fine with where this this ends.
>> I mean, I'm not happy with you that this was done on
stream. I'm not happy with you that you ignored me when I was
trying to talk to you and done. So, I'm not happy that you >> decided
to join VC the second stream >> You could have kicked me
from VC. Why didn't you kick me from VC?
Uh, wait. Why? Why would kicking you >> You clearly don't
care about my feelings because otherwise this situation wouldn't
be happening. So why didn't you just kick me from VC? >> Why
would I kick you from VC? >> Because apparently that's
the reason why I'm here. >> You're here cuz you're want
to talk about it publicly. >> I went to VC because I had
no choice cuz people would have called me a coward or like that
I'm running. >> Okay. So if I didn't talk to you on stream,
people would have called me a coward or said I was running.
>> Yeah. Well, that's the choice you have to make when
you're the streamer. Sometimes you have to eat [__]
right? But it's not my stream. >> Okay.
All right. >> You do realize your stream is your responsibility,
right? The stuff that gets done in your stream is not my responsibility.
So, I don't know why you're laughing at it. >> Realize
that if >> if you didn't want me to talk in PC, >> it's
still public. It still gets >> And you still haven't given
me what you're bothered about me talking about in my Discord
is like, you said you got multiple screenshots. Send me these
screenshots. What is it you're bothered
>> Uh, I don't know about today. >> You don't even
know, but you're like >> Because usually when we have an
argument, you start publicly talking about it in your Discord,
right? >> Yeah. Why would I not vent about like you know
that I do this, so if you had an issue with that, why would you
be friends with me?
>> Okay, that's actually a fair point. >> Cuz I've
stated this is how I felt about things. I will always vent about
petty. I told you this months ago
and like probably
I don't know, like three, four months
>> someone banned Meowies from the chat. Can we get Meowies
out of here? Hold on. Slash unmod
meowies
slashtimeout
>> But why? I feel like I'm going to get blamed for this,
too. >> I can't I just got to block her on Discord, too.
I'm not going to be able to deal with this. Bring up the OCPD
list and play bingo. I don't know what that is. Oh, I don't know
what that is.
that would be really bad for me though, wouldn't it? Not realize
that. Well, I guess I wouldn't realize that. Or I should I should
probably unban Meies before she gets mad at me. Starts leaking
all my DMs with her too.
Only so much I can handle in one day. Uh, >> what DMs have
I leaked of any significance? Like, the amount that I have to
keep to myself,
but the little I leak, but there's nothing important at all.
And it's not like I'm screenshotting your DMs and posting them
everywhere. Like what is the problem? That's being a friend.
Yeah, but if someone's not being a friend to you, if someone
is treating you like a friend, you don't owe them that back.
Jessica was a first. So he's complaining that he's getting what
he serve like what he deserves. I don't you don't get to just
keep repeatedly treating people like and then expecting them
to eat it. >> Okay. The only reason why I bring up the
stuff that I actually know being significantly more than the
stuff that I have leaked is not as a threat
is making a point to just that he's aware of that I know a lot
more that I've never spoken about. It's not as a threat. I don't
know how to like phrase it without it like seeming in that way,
but it's I don't know.
He's kind of implying like I leak all of the stuff we ever talk
about and that's just like not remotely true. And I've never
like leaked anything serious at all. And he knows that too. But
he won't just say it. So I feel like I'm obligated to like say
something like that in response. No, it's not a threat because
I have no intention of doing that whether we're like friends
or not.
Tony said the same thing, but people don't lose their minds when
Tony says it. When Tony says, "I'm fed up logistical. We're not
friends, but I won't actually leak anything like
>> I don't I don't know why. again.
>> I don't know why you didn't just sort things with him.
>> Yeah, if you spoke to him and apologized. Yes. >> Wait,
I spoke to him. >> Wait, hold on. >> I spoke to him.
We're cool.
>> Oh, well that's good.
>> Took a long time though.
>> He sent me this and said there's a hard R in it. Let's
see. Hold on. Was this a clip? What is this clip Tony sent me?
>> Good evening, Nick. Long time Replay viewer. Second
time chatter. During the segment last night, you mentioned vacationing
in county. So, I figured I may as well throw the invitation out
>> what's the thought? You think I'm going to hang out
with you? Well, I don't even know you. Why would I hang out with
you? >> Why is the message
>> the username? So, >> is everyone that watches
a show like this or is it self It's obviously self- selected
for who sends the money.
>> That's the correct way. >> But it's like what
in what universe do you think I'm going to say? Yeah. All right.
I think I will. Like I have no idea who you are. You're watching
the show. You are an anonymous username called
Gorilla. And you think I'm Yeah, why not? >> Yeah, I'll
stay at your and I'm going to sleep there and bathe there and
live
Like, and do you think I'm going to do >> Yeah, obviously.
Gorilla and nuke the bot. We're only on kick. If I We disavow
that, by the way. Totally disavow that. very disgusting language.
But he Tony linked me that and he said not safe for work language.
Not safe for Twitch language. Okay. >> I didn't say
not streaming to the Discord. So I didn't listen to any of it.
So >> the is not funny. He was getting mad. He was That's
not funny. The funny part is him being like >> is hating
his audience. Okay. It's funny that he hates his audience.
>> That's weird. Sorry Postus. You come back tomorrow.
Only do 12 hours. So you're here for the next stream.
What a weird comment, bro. Jtock hates his audience. I just need
to get to the point where I can start like actually significantly
shit-talking. I feel like people donate to Nick just to get [__]
talked to them, right? That's actually why they donate. He hates
his audience so much. I've seen him hate his audience so much.
He'll take like three donations in a stream. He like $300 in
donations. He'll take like the three highest donations and he'll
like go the off on the third person and go like, "That's it.
I can't handle you guys anymore. I'm just ending the stream.
Bye." And he'll leave. He reads his super chats at the end of
the stream.
>> You throw up mute. No, I didn't. Did not do that.
>> Guys, don't forget, okay?
I'm trying to show the Patreon. Join the
>> even at the $5 tier, join the Patreon.
I tried to
I monetized Kelly's VC today. I said Meowies can pull people
in if they have Patreons.
>> Uh, we're going over the conspiracy or not. I need to
know if I should sleep.
>> Hold on.
>> Oh, hold on. Two seconds.
Kelly bffs again. No, I'm still mad. And I don't like the the
thing that I really don't like is when saying I'm unepathetic.
As if I don't have a right to be annoyed in this situation. as
if I had no reason to be upset about any of the stuff that Cherry
said on Twitter and like the comments that get made like passive
aggressively at me. That's what I don't like. The fact that I
have to be empathetic
and that I'm criticized for my lack of empathy as if I should
like I don't have the right to be like
mad at stuff. It's like I'm a human too with feelings and such.
So I don't that's not how anyone works, right?
expecting like empathy from someone that's is like
that's asking a lot especially when just it just feels like being
if criticized for unfairly I suppose unless you startle you will
always lose I would argue justical is losing but
>> unfortunately just not true
>> what has anyone won in this situation
>> what is uh I don't know we're doing I listen you wanted
to talk about this publicly so I was like okay we'll just talk
about it on stream it's fine >> no I wanted to talk about
it in DMs but you ignore my DMs and then you brought it up in
gen chat and then obviously at that point it is public yes >> did
I even mention the straight raid thing in DMs I actually don't
know
>> you didn't
well did I not did I talk about anything except the straight
raid thing in public >> you talked about cherry stuff in
my DMs and then you ignored my DMs when I was asking you questions
And then you brought that stuff up, the straight ra stuff up
in gend chat.
>> It's like a different thing. >> But it's the same
conversation. The straighter a conversation and the cherry conversation
was the same conversation. It started from the same thing.
>> Okay. I don't think so. But I'm saying okay cuz I don't
really want to >> even
I think it is.
But even if it wasn't, there's no reason why you couldn't have
DM'd me. like you
I don't know why you wouldn't instead of like bringing it up
in gent. >> Uh cuz it just seemed like petty and >> It
could have been petty and silly, but you didn't want to treat
it as petty and silly. You wanted to
chastise me and criticize me and then take away my ability to
speak. That's not being petty.
>> Did I take away the ability to speak like way later?
>> Yes, you did. No, you didn't. You let me say two whole
sentences before you turned white names off
>> and then took my perms away so I couldn't speak. >> What?
I'm pretty sure that's not true. Hold on. >> That is true.
I can tell you when I started talking in my Discord cuz that's
when you did that. >> Hold on. Oh, white names could talk
for a long time before the stream though. I did turn them off
for a little bit.
>> Why do you think I was when I messaged
>> Did I message you or not?
>> Perms to Lav. I don't think so.
>> I don't mind. I don't mind uh Lav
>> I don't know if I'm going to unban her from the Discord,
but >> I I unbanned her from the chat. I'm like friends
with Lav, but I just think I think if she's in the Discord, we'll
end up being enemies again or something.
Easier being friends from a distance.
>> it's just easier to be friends from a
>> MLAB moderator for this disagreement.
>> I don't know about that. An interesting
>> Yeah, I said all I got to say was did she complain to
you or what? Who doesn't mute server pings? And then you turned
off my ability to say anything. And then I posted a single like
a few things in the e. >> Wait, didn't we argue about it?
I thought you made all these points about Nicholas Dioro and
all this other
>> Yeah. No, there wasn't much arguing. There was like
four sentences that I see here. I pinged Dioro 10 times calling
him fat. Pinging people is harassment when I like them. Did she
just complain to you or what? Who doesn't mute server pings?
That's all I said. >> I got annoyed
that uh what were you doing? I got annoyed that you were like
you're doing your thing where you just totally evade the actual
like problem. So, you weren't actually allowing pettiness to
exist. You were just silencing me. Was actually true. >> Sounds
pretty petty to me.
>> Pettiness is when you actually get to say something.
You're like trying to control things.
>> You had access to every other channel.
>> Okay. Who reads the rest of the
>> That's not where the conversation was being had. I would
have assumed that you were making a point by removing my ability
to speak and that you didn't want me to speak. So, I went to
my Discord to speak and then I spoke to >> Yeah, I know.
>> Yeah, I know. You know,
Okay. All right. Uh,
>> Jesus Christ. Should we cover this um conspiracy stuff,
guys?
>> I think I silenced everybody. Chase Arc. Literally everyone.
>> That wasn't literally everyone. That was just white
names. >> Yeah, that's like literally everyone. >> That's
not literally everyone, is it? >> Literally mostly. >> All
of your Patreon subs. Also, you have literally no Patreon and
kick subs. Is that true? >> I got a couple Patreon subs.
There's like three of them.
>> Yeah, but your kick chatters can now talk, right? You
said you were doing >> I think I let kickers talk for a
little bit. I don't know if I don't know if we're going to keep
doing that that same experiment. We'll see. >> I do not
want to do any dailies, but appreciate being asked. I'm going
to go. I think Jessica I don't know if Jessica's aware that I
am actually I think he thinks that he thinks this is funny. I'm
not really sure, but I'm not
>> I also don't I just don't appreciate being giving an
empathy lecture from
>> I think that if you gave a [__] about any
of this, you would have spoken to me in private. I think that
if you're going to make this public content, then you also don't
give a [__] So, you don't get the right to like moral
frog me.
Uh, I just was um, >> yeah, I just saw you in Discord doing
your thing, you know, normal thing. So, >> yeah, my normal
thing
>> doesn't discount your responsibilities, your decisions,
and how you are. Okay, you can't get to say, "Oh, Kelly, you're
so unempathetic." whilst you farm the unempathetic content. >> And
it's not like you're empathetic.
Why did you join me? >> When has ever been empathy towards
me in any situation ever, even a crumb? >> Okay. I've never
had any empathy towards
>> Somebody I I just want you today when you were making
I need to hop on stream. Give me a call. Okay. Give me a call
on Discord. I need you to cam up and show me your actual reaction
to her saying that I've never shown her empathy. Okay.
>> I need to see your actual face when you hear the line.
JTO's never shown me any empathy. Do you think it was empathetic
to bring up the pickle when you know what you're doing when you're
doing that? Did you think it was empathetic of you to bring up
pretty traumatic my in your gen chat in like January or like
when you had to like ban that again or like when you brought
it up on stream or when your community ended up like
>> pictures of me? Was that empathetic?
>> Hey, don't say my community. Uh the people who did that
are banned from here. Okay, that's spin boy. well known Destiny.gg
Discord chatter compsai regular Spinboy that that's who posting
underage underage pictures of >> He wasn't banned for that.
He wasn't banned for that and he's not banned now for that. And
that wasn't just Spinboy doing it or engaging in it or encouraging
it. And the pickle definitely isn't banned. You don't care about
any of the he's done to me or said to me. So where's the >> I
think the pickle might be banned. The cucumber though. The cucumber
guy. I don't know if that guy. Well, don't like lecture me about
empathy when apparently you don't care about what other people
have said to me about something that's very traumatic to me.
You don't care, do you? But you're sitting on your high horse
being like, "Kelly, why aren't you more empathetic to this person
that's being atrocious to you? I just think you're full of
Maddie sent me this." Yeah. >> Are you going to actually
respond to anything I've just said, or is it just fine for you
to be a hypocrite and just not engage with that?
>> To be a hypocrite? I wasn't. So
what what are you saying? Do you want to
>> Was it empathetic of you to like bring up the stuff
relating to the pickle into those things? >> It's one to
one directly comparable.
>> How what did I bring up that was traumatic of yours?
>> Uh traumatic of cherries.
>> Did I bring it up to be cruel? No.
>> She brought it up herself today. >> Or did I bring
up something where you were being possibly cruel? like maybe
even unintentionally cruel, right? And I brought it up to say
like, "Hey, the other person sees this as cruel. Do you think
you should like have any concern for that at all?" They they
are the person who's bringing it up says, "I'm not being cruel.
I'm actually I'm actually just pointing out that nobody here
will call this person on this."
That is what the pickle thinks, right? That that literally nobody
will call you on your
salt. That's the is my salt. >> I don't think he I don't
think he thinks that. So, it would it be okay if people didn't
think the bad thing happened to Cherry. Would that be okay to
harass her like he's harassed me for 6 months? If they said,
"Oh, I don't really think that thing happened to Cherry, so I
can just like harass her constantly."
>> No, that wouldn't be okay. Obviously, would it you [__]
So, you're sitting there lecturing me about empathy when you've
no when have you demonstrated it for me? You you understand you
understand that I'm bringing up like the the comp the comparison
here is that you think you're not doing anything wrong because
you think you're I'm saying what's true, right? Even though it
like hurts somebody else, you're saying I'm saying what's true.
I don't really like it's not my problem. I don't have to deal
with this, right? And I'm telling you that's how the pickle sees
it. >> No, that's not justified. That is not an argument
that you're justified. >> That's not what I'm doing. That
is not what I'm doing. She brought up exat traumatic event in
the chat today.
It wasn't me that brought it up and I never brought it up in
any kind of negative context. I was saying it in the point that
I won't talk about that because I and I don't understand why
she's brought it up twice to me. I would not be talking about
it now if she had not done that twice. >> Okay. That's
not what I'm talking about, but it's fine.
>> Well, I don't know what you mean then.
>> Okay. I had not at any point said anything like cruel
about a traumatic event today. That is just like not true. >> Sorry.
What did I What did I say that was cruel about a traumatic event?
>> I'm just going to say okay. >> No, don't just
say okay. You're accusing me of doing something I haven't done.
or type it to me if you don't want to say it. >> I told
Kelly I had hemorrhoids in VC earlier and she said that was good
by the way. >> Okay. Can you like >> I don't I don't
feel I don't I honestly don't feel really safe typing it >> if
I what that's just
>> I think that you're full of I don't think that's true.
if I've said it publicly.
>> I don't know what you're referring to, but like why
would you not be able to just tell me in DMs?
>> Uh, I'm just good with moving on now. >> How can
you move on if you don't ever properly talk about anything? >> Oh,
you talk about >> Sorry. What is How can you move on?
>> No, but I don't like the idea. No, I I publicly I'm
not happy with the fact that you're implying that I brought up
someone's trauma today to like dump on it because that's not
true.
>> now it's okay to do in private apparently. Could have
been done hours
>> Uh, I was going to stream about Destiny. I wasn't going
to talk about this at all. You're the person who forced it into
public, Kelly.
>> You're the one who forced it on stream. >> Do
you not take responsibility for the >> Do you not take
responsibility for your part in things? These things don't happen
to go live and talk about something totally unrelated.
>> These things don't happen in a vacuum. Your decisions
and your part in things plays to a thing happening. I can't argue
by myself and cause these things to happen on my own. That's
not possible. And the fact that you're just trying to dump all
responsibility onto me is strange. >> You didn't have to
join the Discord here where I'm streaming. >> And you didn't
have to drag me in and you didn't have to stream it.
>> These are decisions you made, too. I understand that
I made decisions, but you seem to not understand that you made
decisions and you played a part in this. >> I played a
part in this. You played a part in this. >> Yes. But that
I'm I'm never I've never said I didn't play any part in it. I'm
saying that we played an equal part. But you don't want to admit
that. No, I just said that's true. I just said that. Yes, I think
that >> earlier. Okay. >> You never asked me.
>> I believe you said you're the streamer. You control
everything that goes on here. It's entirely irresponsible >> with
a stream. Yes. With everything else that led up to the stream.
No. Obviously, I was equally responsible for that. But I'm not
responsible for you streaming.
That part is obviously not true. I don't have the stop or start
stream button.
>> I'm clearly quite and I I feel like it's fairly clear
by the fact I was trying to DM you that I wanted to talk about
this in private, but you were being a
and ignoring me.
>> No, guys. Guys, Kelly's disconnect button doesn't work.
>> Sorry. What does my disconnect button have to do with
your decision to stream?
>> Sorry. Uh, am I not correct that your your choice to
stream is your decision when it comes to making content? >> That
part >> I was going to stream on, but you decided to go
and turn my Discord into >> I'm sorry. Do you have any
autonomy? Do you do you have autonomy?
>> I do.
>> So, your stream is your decision. Yes. Nobody else's
responsibility is your stream. Somebody is going to discord queen
it up in in my in my public
>> about you're using another destinism, are you? You're
using another destining
it up. Yes, it is. >> Yes, it is. >> It's really
not. It is a concept that reaches far beyond destiny. >> Yes,
it is. >> I understand that if you learn if you learn of
something from destiny, that's why you think it exists. I get
it. You're criticizing him me for the reason that you know he
has said against me. That's what you're doing.
>> Uh okay. And what >> I don't normally join >> when
I go live and then you join a VC to talk about me. >> What
do you What do I think it is that people were asking me to and
I would have got called a coward if I hadn't. I don't think that's
being a Discord queen. I think Discord queens sit around in VC
all day.
I don't Do you disagree that your stream is your responsibility?
I'm like baffled by this. The fact that you're trying to like
offload some of that to me is bizarre. For everything that happened
happened in Gen Chat, sure. Whatever I say in my Discord,
>> I can't get So, Kelly, you have your own Discord, okay?
Your own Discord client. I can't force you to be connected to
any channel. Actually, I can't do that. Okay. I don't have the
power. So, I think ultimately you have to accept your own responsibility
here. Okay? You have the power to be connected to
your connected to a VC. I'm not talking about that. I'm talking
about your choice to make content and what you put on your stream
is entirely your choice and entirely under your control. This
was a choice. You're acting like I'm holding you hostage. You
can kick me at any point. >> You're acting like I'm holding
you hostage. You can disconnect at any >> No, you're not
holding me hostage at all. This is my choice to be here. But
your stream content is entirely your
>> Okay. So, you're choosing to be here, but you would
not choose you you are not choosing to be on stream, but you're
just choosing to be in the Discord call with me. >> I'm
choosing to have this discussion with you. It's not my choice
to make content because I don't have control over that aspect.
It's not my stream. I don't have control over that part. >> Do
you have control over your ability to make content or the over
the ability to
>> You could just not be here. And when you weren't on
the Discord, where you weren't a VC, I was covering other >> That
has nothing to do with your choice of what you choose to put
on your
>> Those are two different things. >> This could
just be mirrored infinitely. You know that, right? >> I
mean, if you're being willfully like
>> I can just copy your exact like reasoning for any of
these things, right? Well, I can't leave. I can't I can't not
talk about this cuz people will call me a coward and say I ran.
>> That was just for VC. That's not for up here. I'm not
even applying that here. I'm explaining how that series of events
happened and I'm simply saying >> is making content out
of this bad. >> I think that No, I think that you criticizing
my lack of empathy whilst you if you think that I'm so unempathetic
and that that is bad and that I'm harming people and it's hurtful,
then I think that if you were so empathetic, you wouldn't turn
that into content.
>> Because you just said it's harmful. Do you not think
it's harmful to like broadcast things that you've accused me
of? To like >> I didn't say it was harmful. I said it like
frustrated me. It frustrates me that your empathy can work for
people who are nice to you and the second they aren't nice to
you, that empathy disappears entirely.
>> Has Cherry multiple times in the past not been nice
to me in the last 6 >> I don't know. >> What do you
mean you don't know? I've spoken to you on multiple occasions
about it. Okay. Was I empathetic then? >> I don't know.
So the part where she said that I sent her the nicest message.
You don't you've forgotten that willfully. >> I think she
said it was a nice message. I don't know if she said the nicest
>> She You told me it was the nicest message. You told
me that.
>> And then she tweeted basically the same
>> Okay. So you keep trying to imply that I've never been
nice and kind and understanding to her the multiple times that
she's blocked me and said mean
>> What do you think you just said implied? You're saying
that Kelly is never understanding or empathetic.
>> When someone isn't being nice to her. I've just given
you examples.
>> Oh, actually you just you put the critical piece there
for me. Yes. Not nice to >> She said No, she said things
publicly before too, but not to this extent. But the thing is
like if she had done something about it in the last week, >> exactly
what it was. >> No, that's
>> Firstly, that's not true.
because I've been on the stream with you after she tweeted a
bunch of about me and I didn't start her, did I?
>> I've only said nice things and I said to other people
who were questioning me about it to like not speak about it.
You can go back a week in the chat and you can see how the tweets
that are getting posted about me, I'm just not engaging with.
I'm not saying anything mean. I'm not encouraging people to be
cruel. I'm not encouraging any harassment. I'm saying just like
I'm trying to be as understanding as I possibly can.
>> What do you have any issue with anything I had said
prior to now?
>> I've been on the stream with you since then. Yes. Do
you think it's possible that today it was just a boiling point
and that was mad for like valid reasons
>> because Cherry said, um, I'm not going after your streamer
going after you after you pinged Straight Raid right after Cherry
linked her stream.
She was accusing me of harassing straighter raid. So yes, I took
that like passive aggressive comment and I was annoyed by it.
But nothing I said >> taking every opportunity on stream
to actually say straight raid like needs to say something up
the straight raid's not >> This isn't about straight raid
four days in the discord. You add >> this isn't about
this isn't about straight raid. This conversation is about cherry.
You're trying to like diverge. there's a reasonable expectation
that like Sherry's stream gets posted and then you at and you
like start going after her again or not in this case going after
her but you haven't been going after you at her again that some
people might be concerned about that. >> I think that the
passive aggressive comment she wrote is fairly obviously going
to annoy me and then the follow-up passive aggressive comment
was obviously going to annoy me. I think that if she cared that
much she would have been like hey don't tag her or something
normal like everyone else put.
But that's not what she did and that's not how the conversation
went. And I didn't say anything cruel to her. I was just obviously
kind of annoyed. It's fine for me to be annoyed by the things
she did. >> I think Well, I think pretty much everybody
here would agree that your like your comment there is pretty
uh was kind of cruel, right? >> Sorry. What What comment
was cruel?
>> That's I don't even want to talk. You like stop understanding.
>> You keep saying I don't want to talk about it. I don't
know what cuz I then I'm like I have to explicitly explain to
you like what everybody else sees there
>> Yeah. You don't Okay. Which comment like all the time
>> because there was a conversation and I don't know what
message you're referring
>> Just like post it to me in DMs if you don't want to
read it out.
>> Is the mean message girl I don't care. Go tweet about
how you don't like my clothes some more. Is that the cruel mean
message we're referring to? I >> just because someone else
has posted that. I'm sorry, but that is not cruel. >> Oh,
what was the context of her posting that message? >> The
bit about my clothes, how I'm like not wearing anything apparently.
>> When was she posting that? >> When was she posting
that? I don't know. Monday or Tuesday. Or is it Wednesday? I
don't know. >> What was going on with her on Monday or
>> I don't know. But she obviously wasn't in the facility
or she wouldn't be able to tweet, would she? >> Okay, this
one I know cuz I told you that she was just getting home. >> I'm
confused what that means.
>> I know. No, I don't. How is that relating to my cruelty
today? Apparently, what did you mean by girl? I don't What do
you mean? What did I mean by girl? If my comment was cruel, what
does that make her comments? Or are we not allowed to criticize
any of the things she says? Am I just supposed to like take it
every instance because you >> No, you don't have to. You
can make your decisions when you want to get mad at somebody
about something. >> If that's true, then why is this an
issue? Why does that mean I'm like a critically
incapable of showing empathy?
>> Saying Kelly is not allowed to be upset about stuff.
That's what it feels like.
>> Do you understand the disconnect between how you feel
emotionally and what your actions should be based on those
I don't well
I if you're saying like conceptually yes I understand that people
can say meaner when they're angry but for me this was incredibly
reserved and as I'm looking at it now and I can evaluate it again
tomorrow when I'm less mad I don't think that was over the top
by my standards I normally eviscerate people when they me off
there isn't a single person I've given as much grace as I have
to Jerry because Most people don't do what she does, so there's
like no reason to.
>> Mhm. I don't think you understand how passive aggressive
you get basically all the time with people who you like annoy
you slightly. >> Okay. Based on what? I'm pretty direct
with people.
Why would I need to be passive
>> Also, Cherry was being passive aggressive to me, so
like I don't It's okay when she does it again, I guess.
Kelly is such a She demands so much from others. Did you not
see the tweet she made about me? She said some unhinged.
>> I didn't do anything to provoke that.
>> Also, that message doesn't include the message from
before I said that. That wasn't like the first thing she said.
I don't know how we're behaving like, "Girl, I don't care. Go
tweet about how you don't like like my colisam is like some cruel
comment." Like, that's
>> People say worse than that in the Discord every hour.
I don't What are you me at?
>> Like, how?
Sorry. Explain to me how that is incredibly cruel. So what does
that make the thing she said about me? >> I didn't say
incredibly cruel. >> Is it?
>> What? I I literally just said no. >> So what is
the problem with that response just cuz it wasn't kind? I agree.
It's not kind.
>> Where Cherry was and what was going on and what her
mind state was when she tweeted that. And so I think bringing
that up when she's basically saying, "Sorry, I'm just going to
separate myself from this because it feels weird, right?" I think
>> why would I know about her mindset
>> when she hadn't spoken to me? No, you
>> You hadn't even spoken to her properly at this point.
I've been away all weekend. What conversation do you think that
we had at any point? I have to ask you about things at every
opportunity. And then you delete things like I don't know what
you think you've told me but it's not much in this last week
and I've been busy the last few days.
>> It's also really annoying that the amount of times I
asked you is Cherry okay? How is Cherry doing? And you're like
Kelly doesn't have empathy. It's just like really dismissive
of anything I've ever done and said. It's like if you actually
genuinely think that of me, then I probably should just leave
cuz I don't I just feel like a idiot cuz I spent so much time
like helping you through with
only for it to get like thrown back in my face on so many
>> Oh, we actually talked through explicitly. I I remember
this now. >> We actually talked through like explicitly
what was going on and why like what her mind state was. you remember
explicitly the DMs that you
>> Yeah, I'll just show you what you said and you'll remember
that we actually talked I actually explicitly said what you should
Google to know like why she tweeted that and how she was feeling
about it. And actually, realistically, you should know just from
this conversation alone that you probably shouldn't have been
referencing back. >> I will respond to this in like DM
cuz I assume he'll just get mad at me.
Yes. I had no idea. You gave me no details at all. You told me.
She told me she should Google this term that I already knew for
explicit reason.
>> You gave me no. You told me. I'm sorry, but they're
doing the smoke. Mhm. >> Sorry. Like it's just really dismissive.
>> We just had Yeah, I know. We just had the Wolf Gang
thing happen again.
>> We just had nothing. We just had like the thing happen
again where it's like I I basically told you the information.
You were like
I was like don't do this thing. You're like sorry. I was like
this thing makes this person this person feels bad and here's
the reason. You're like well you didn't say don't bring it up
again.
>> I didn't bring that up at all. I will write this out.
>> Nothing. I am speaking in code people don't understand.
>> Like I didn't bring that up. I don't know what you're
on about.
>> We've gotten donations to let Kelly speak. So I got
to let Kelly speak right
Talk is a meditation stream. Yes,
Silence is saying a lot. Is it? Oh, what the hell? It's why.
It's why this should work. Come on. God damn it. Hold on.
>> Hold on. I'm fixing something, guys.
>> I don't even want to talk about it.
>> But apparently Justical thinks that something that somebody
does after a quotation traumatic event is the same as referencing
someone's actual traumatic event, which I disagree with. I didn't
reference any traumatic event. >> Okay. But also, I think
that if you're an empathetic person, you wouldn't try and be
cruel to someone else to quotation prove or show how that how
it feels. I think that that >> you being cruel. I didn't
reference a >> You were being cruel. >> I didn't
reference a traumatic >> You brought up the pickle and
what he doesn't says because you know that that's what he doesn't
says. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. But it's it's literally
several steps removed from a traumatic event. I didn't
several steps removed. It's not that's all he does is bring up
that stuff
and the same person and you know that it's not any steps removed.
He harasses me about that specific topic.
>> It's not about things that he It's not about things
that I did after the event.
>> You're comparing someone being traumatized to someone
who is traumatized doing some things afterwards. Those are not
the same things. Okay. >> Yes, being traumatized means
that you can be and do things and I can have some understanding
for that. But comparing them and saying that those are the same
things is not fair.
>> But this has not been without its price.
>> I didn't bring up pickle. Just brought up pickle. So
that's why it's a topic for conversation. Don't blame me for
it. >> Though we stand at the height of >> and yes,
he hasn't really said anything in the last
few weeks that I've been >> Sure. I don't know when he
stopped being >> really good behavior. Although I don't
know if he actually was around at all
>> good behavior might be really
>> feel like watching stuff with sound. I have no clue.
>> No, I might have had some sound too loud there. Oh god.
Oh, all my mods are going to be broken. >> All right, I'm
just leaving. I Yeah, I don't know what to say. What someone
does after a traumatic event is not the same as bringing up someone's
trauma. And that's just implying that someone who's been traumatized
can therefore be forever and do whatever they like without any
criticism, which is nonsense.
Just cuz you're traumatized doesn't mean you shouldn't take responsibility
for the things that you've done. >> Okay, that pickle,
I get it. >> No, I don't think you do. And I think that
you'll bring this up at any other opportunity if you want to
take a swipe at me because I think that you're just a massive
hypocrite. >> I didn't want to take a swipe at you. Didn't
want to just take a swipe at you. It was literally like >> You
did by doing that. You did that to show me how it feels. to show
you that it is the same thing that's happening. There's the same
mechanism at play
>> It's not the same thing. If you felt that that thing
that I did was traumatizing someone and making them upset by
bringing that stuff up, you just did the same thing to me. You
don't care about that thing. You only care about it when it's
done to the one person you care about at the time. >> I
didn't bring it up. I brought up the pickle. The pickle did not
participate in that event. He was not part of that
He talks about only that thing when it was harassing me. That
is directly related.
It's talking He harasses me about that event. He doesn't harass
me about something I did after the event. >> He But he
wasn't the event. He's not the >> No, he's not the event.
But now you're basically saying the event. >> He's not
the event. But then you're saying the only person that like can
bring that up is my like ex that everyone else that brings it
up is then doing it indirectly. That's stupid. The point is the
topic. The topic is your soul. The topic is the trauma. I didn't
bring up her trauma. I brought up her tweaks for sakes. And you're
trying to make them the same. >> They were made when >> after
she was Ouch.
>> They weren't while she They weren't her trauma. They're
not the same things. Whatever happened to her that made her traumatized
wasn't the tweets.
The tweets are the expression at most afterwards.
Those are not the same thing. It's not Kelly logic. They're just
not the same thing. It's like the difference would be me on her
for being in a facility versus me saying, "Hey, those tweets
were about me were" and then making fun of that. If this is what
you think, then yeah, I give up them. >> I'm kind of >> Empathy
is only for Cherry, none for Gilly. I will not be here next time.
You need the pieces picking up again cuz I'm sick of it.
drama. I was just like kind of over discussing it. Like I I basically
like